يشيد الكثير من الشرق الأوسط بهذا
الاتفاق التاريخي بين
المتنافسين الإقليميين المملكة العربية السعودية وإيران، وقد تم
الاختراق الدبلوماسي بوساطة
الصين وأعلن عنه في بكين يوم الجمعة
أو الكثير في هذه المنطقة وتذكر أننا
نبث من الإمارات العربية المتحدة، وهذا هو
بثنا في الشرق الأوسط كيف  ويأمل الكثيرون في
هذه المنطقة أن
يؤدي هذا الاتفاق إلى حقبة جديدة من
انخفاض العداء في بعض
مناطق الصراع الأكثر تعقيدًا في المنطقة
مثل اليمن والعراق والإمارات العربية المتحدة التي
تعرضت للقصف في يناير 2022 بصواريخ
وطائرات بدون طيار أطلقتها من اليمن.
رحب المتمردون الحوثيون بالاتفاق وقالوا
إنهم يقدرون دور الصين في المفاوضات
جيدًا. ضيفي التالي يقول إنه يجب أن
تكون هناك فترة لبناء الثقة وإجراءات
على الأرض لتعزيز هذا الاتفاق.
قد يكون البعض متشككًا في
النوايا السعودية أو يصف هذا بالفعل بأنه اتفاق أمريكي.  -من
الواضح أنهم ليسوا على اطلاع
بالسياسة المعلنة للمملكة
جيدًا، هذه هي كلمات فيصل عباسو هو
رئيس تحرير عرب نيوز وهو
ينضم إلي الآن على الهواء مباشرة، فقط دعنا نفصل ذلك
إذا أردنا ودعونا نرى  إذا أمكننا
التوسع في ما كتبته هنا أه
أنت تتحدث عن
السياسة المعلنة للممالك أعتقد أنك
هنا تتحدث عن سياستهم
الدبلوماسية أولاً عصر جديد من
الدبلوماسية أولاً والذي تراه ليس
فقط في هذه المنطقة أه ولكن حولها
العالم دعنا نتحدث فقط عن هذه
السياسة المعلنة الجديدة وكيف أن هذا
الاتفاق بين السعودية وإيران يتناسب مع
ذلك
أه حسنًا بيكي أولاً شكرًا
جزيلاً لك على استضافتي أه في
كلمات سان تزو الحكيمة في كتاب فن الكتاب الشهير
للأفضل  المعارك واحدة دون
قتال
أم لذلك إذا كان هذا الاتفاق يمكن أن يساعدنا في
تحقيق أهدافنا أه يوصلنا إلى حيث
نريد أن نكون في 2030
أم وهذا الفصل الدموي الذي
عشناه أه
المنطقة كلها عاشته لعقود من الزمن
فهو  فوز أه على جميع الجبهات الآن
كان هناك بعض العوامل الجيوسياسية
التي ساعدت في التغيير أه أو
سرعت هذه العملية كما أنت
جيد جدًا أه ربما أتذكر جيدًا أه في
بداية
إدارة بايدن كان هناك بعض غير
مطمئن جدًا أ  تم إرسال الرسالة
عندما تم القضاء على الحوثيين من
الإرهابيين وسحب بطاريات باتريوت
من المملكة العربية السعودية في
الوقت الذي تم فيه استهداف مدنيينا ومدننا لنا
في المملكة العربية
السعودية لدينا رؤية واضحة للغاية ونحن
نتجه نحو 23
للتنويع  بعيدًا عن النفط، نريد
ترفيهًا على مستوى عالمي، نريد
فتح قطاعات جديدة، وهذه
فرصة ليس للسعوديين فحسب، بل
لكل شخص في العالم يريد أن يأتي
ويعيش هنا ويساهم في
الاقتصاد المزدهر، ونحن لا نريد
أي شيء يخاطر
بتحقيق ذلك الآن إذا اختارت إيران
البقاء في عام 1979، فهذا خيارهم ولكننا
بالتأكيد نريد الذهاب إلى عام 2030 ولا
يمكننا أن نحصل على ذلك مع تحليق الطائرات بدون طيار
والصواريخ فوق رؤوسنا،
هناك شيئان أعتقد أنه يجب علينا
استكشافهما هنا، فلنتحدث عنهما
ثبات
هذه الصفقة أه بين السعودية وإيران
ثم أريد أن أتحدث عن
الآثار المترتبة على
علاقة المملكة معنا لأن بعض
ما كنت أه للتو أه تصفه
هناك كثيرًا أه يقع في هذا الدلو
فلنتحدث عنه  أه العلاقات الإيرانية السعودية
كانت هناك سنوات من
العداء وهؤلاء ليسوا منافسين إقليميين
أم من تعلم أن هذا
التنافس قد خلق بالفعل الكثير من
الصراع والأزمات في جميع أنحاء هذه المنطقة
فكيف
تتوقع المملكة الحصول على هذه
الصفقة  الضربة التي وجهوها إلى إيران،
إنهم يوجهونها إلى شركة تيكران قبل شهرين من
إعادة فتح السفارات، ما الذي
يحتاجون إلى رؤيته في هذين الشهرين ليصدقوا
تمامًا أن تفلون موجود على متن الطائرة، حسنًا،
أعتقد أن الجميع وخاصة
في هذا الجزء من العالم وخاصة
في المملكة واضح المعالم
وتاريخ إيران يتحدث عن نفسه وللأسف
التاريخ لديه طريقة ليكرر نفسه
لذا
هناك الكثير من الاهتمام
بالتفاصيل وربما هذا هو السبب كما
ذكرت للتو أه لم يتم
توقيع الصفقة  تم منحه شهرين على الفور، وهو
ما أعتقد أنه قرار حكيم للغاية فيما
يتعلق بالتفاصيل الجوهرية أو
للاتفاق على التفاصيل تحت أي ظرف من
الظروف، ألا نتوقع أن
نستيقظ في صباح اليوم التالي
ويعانق الجميع فجأة
كما قلت سابقًا  هذا صراع
مستمر منذ أه منذ
عقود كانت هناك أه
محاولات عتاب سابقة لكنها
فشلت أساسا بسبب عدم التزام إيران
بجانبها من أه الصفقة لكن
لنبقي أه نراقب الكرة هنا
اه ما يمكن أن يحققه هذا من خلال
أه كوننا واقعيين أه إذا أردنا أن
نكون واقعيين هذه هي الخطوة الأولى
نحو مستقبل مثير للغاية أه
وأنا نعيش في هذه المنطقة تخيل أن
تستيقظ يومًا ما أه بدون
حرب  في اليمن أه بدون
صراع في سوريا مع
لبنان مزدهر مع عودة العراق إلى كامل
إمكاناته أه يكون ذلك حلم
يتحقق ويكون خير للمنطقة
كلها والعالم كله أه
ما هذا هو الأول  خطوة نحو
هذا الاتجاه ولكن لا أعتقد أن أي شخص
يتوقع منا أن نصل إلى هناك بسرعة ولا أعتقد أن
أي شخص يتوقع منا أه
أن نرمش أثناء العملية ولكن
البيان الأخير الصادر عن
وزارة الخارجية الإيرانية اليوم فقط
هو في الواقع  إن قول ذلك هو
شعور مطمئن للغاية بأن ما قالوه
هو أن هذا قد يؤدي إلى
حل في اليمن وبالطبع لا أحد
في كامل قواه العقلية لا يرغب في أن
يكون ذلك صحيحًا،
ماذا يعني هذا بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة،
أعنيك  أعلم أنه من المهم أن تكون هذه
صفقة توسطت فيها الصين، حيث تتمتع كل من إيران والمملكة
العربية السعودية
بعلاقة اقتصادية جيدة للغاية مع الصين، فهل
يشير هذا إلى أن هذه العلاقة تجعل
الصين أوسع نطاقًا كضامن للأمن
في المستقبل، وتلعب الصين
دورًا أكبر في الشرق الأوسط.  على حساب
الولايات المتحدة ما هي
أفكارك
أم أعتقد أن أولئك الذين يجادلون بوجهة
النظر هذه في الولايات المتحدة بحاجة إلى ما
يسمونه يأخذون حبة دواء للحظة
وينظرون إليها من نوع ما من
مصالحهم الخاصة أه منظور أمريكا  لديهم
الكثير ليكسبوه من استقرار أه الشرق الأوسط
ليس فقط من حيث السوق ولكن من حيث
أه
التزاماتهم العسكرية والاستخباراتية أه لهذا
الجزء من العالم والتفكير في
المرور عبر البحر الأحمر
والأمن البحري لذلك هذا  أولا وقبل كل شيء، أولا وقبل كل شيء،
من المصلحة المطلقة
للولايات المتحدة أن يكون هناك شرق أوسط مستقر وآمن.
ثانيا، كما
تعلمون، لم يكن الأمر كما لو أن الولايات المتحدة
تقدمت إلى المملكة العربية السعودية باقتراح
لحل هذا الأمر وتم رفضه ولكن
الحقيقة المجردة هي أنه إذا وضعنا جانبًا
الحساسيات التي لا أعتقد أنها
ضرورية، فإن هذه خطوة منطقية جدًا
للأمام بمعنى أن طبيعة
هذه الاتفاقيات يجب أن تكون محاطة
بالسرية حتى تكون ناجحة،
والشيء الآخر هو  أنت بحاجة إلى وسيط
يحظى بالثقة من كلا الجانبين. الآن،
ليس لدى الصين تاريخ من العدوان أو
الاستعمار في المنطقة، فهي ليست مثل
الولايات المتحدة أو المملكة المتحدة أو فرنسا،
حتى أنها لديها في معظم القضايا في الشرق
الأوسط، وقد ظلت محايدة تركز
على التجارة.  فيما يتعلق بالتجارة والأهم من ذلك،
وأود أن أقول إن هذا هو أنك
تعرف العامل في هذه المعادلة، وهو أن
لديها بالفعل نفوذًا على الصين،
آسف، لقد استخدمت الصين نفوذها بالفعل
على إيران، فهي أكبر شريك تجاري لإيران. تكنولوجيا
المعلومات تزود إيران
بالتكنولوجيا النووية بالمعدات والتكنولوجيا العسكرية
و  لقد استثمرت المليارات في
صناعة الغاز والنفط والغاز في
إيران، لذا إذا كان لدى أي شخص نفوذ على
إيران فهو الصين، وهذا هو سبب
نجاح هذه الأسهم